tamales mean warmth we were together as
a family this delicious treat that we
all made it together i think of family
hi i'm edna and today i'm making tamales
from mexico when you are making tamales
you want to soak the corn husks until
they're pliable my mom just fills up the
sink and throws them in overnight or
throws them in in the morning before
work comes home they're ready to go
before i went to culinary school i was
like oh i know mexican food mexican food
is this and this type of ceviche and
these type of tamales but then i saw the
variety like so many other families make
tamales so many different ways in just
mexico alone i couldn't imagine learning
every single different culture and the
type of tamales they have tamales mean
warmth i mean we use them for like every
big occasion holidays birthdays every
once in a while my mom just randomly
feels like making tamales and those are
the best days so the meat you want to
cook until it's pretty brown and the fat
is all dried up for the most part you
want the sauce to do the rehydrating and
softening you want it to be pork tender
growing up my mom used to save me a
couple of the dry bits of pork before
adding the sauce but this was obviously
after i had already snuck a couple of
them myself
i think what makes mexico really really
beautiful is that each state has such a
variety honestly the fillings are
endless you can go from savory to sweet
it's really up to you and the family or
country you want to prepare the masa
itself by adding the lard baking soda
baking powder and a little bit of water
mix it all by hand because that's the
best way to do it it's all about the
feel with the masa masa is smooth but
firm and soft as a chef i think it's
very important to keep traditions alive
and i love sharing my family's recipes
because it keeps them going on forever i
think what makes my family's stomachs is
really my mom i feel like making tamales
makes me just that much closer to her
she is such a strong figure in my family
strong and powerful and the cook the
everything really i hope to be like my
mom one day i had her send me recipes
and she made little clips of her making
it little tutorials for me from far so i
hope i make her proud with these
hey there i'm ivan and today i'm making
the puerto rican pastel la lluca
pastelas de luca are little pockets of
yucca dough filled with pork wrapped in
banana leaves so what makes puerto rican
pastels de luca so special is that we
cook the pork with so much flavor and
seasoning and also the way we use yucca
as our dough just flavor and seasoning
that's kind of like the key of a
delicious puerto rican meal the very
first time i had a pastel de luca was
when my grandma made it for the family
at a christmas eve dinner it was the
most delicious thing i've ever had but
definitely this recipe is made by my mom
but i feel like my dad usually always
tries to take over and then he's the one
that says oh look what i made
but yeah i feel like it's a combination
of both working together in the kitchen
and i feel like that's so lovely because
it makes it even more special one of the
best memories that i have making pastels
with my parents are getting messy when i
was a child i really didn't know how to
cook so i would try to help but instead
i would just start playing with the
dough and that was pretty much my help
so now it's finally time to assemble our
delicious pastels de luca but first we
have to heat up the banana leaves so
that they're pliable so some families
add raisins and capers to their pasteles
de luca and some even add garbanzo beans
which i've never had a pastel with
garbanzo bean but i guess that's a thing
my family never adds any of those things
we like to just let the meat speak for
itself so whenever i bite into a pastel
de juga the flavor immediately hits and
it's just like a tangy salty but also a
little bit sweet from the yuca flavor
and it's just so delicious and then you
bite even more into the meat and then
it's like a burst of flavor with the
seasoning and all the spices and it's
just
so i would add ketchup to my pastels and
my dad especially would get so mad
because he would say i spend so much
time giving this pastel flavor and now
you're gonna spread ketchup all over it
that's so disrespectful and i will just
laugh because i was like well i like it
with ketchup so i'm gonna eat it with
ketchup i love pastels de juca so much i
feel like it's that tiny piece of home
that i get to keep even if i live miles
and miles away from home so it
definitely brings all my family together
and i feel like that's something very
important for puerto ricans in general
oh my god my mom will be so proud hey
i'm irwin and today i'm going to show
you how to make guatemalan patches
patchas are guatemalan tamales these are
made with tomato wait not tomato
potatoes
but patches are the best tamales in
latin america what i remember i was
around six years old the first time when
i tried patches and they were really
good you never can forget this taste
because when you're eating apache the
taste is like the most beautiful thing
in the world and it's so delicious so
the patches are really important for me
because remember me when i was little
all the family was together and we
always eat patches on saturdays which is
something like most of the family does
in guatemala it's really special it's
something cultural that we always do so
i live in los angeles my wife and my
kids live so far away from here they
live in guatemala and i'm really excited
because i'm gonna see them soon and i
know they're excited as well we make a
lot of tamales we make like more than
100 tamales we all giving to the
neighbors so it's really special because
when you're taking tamales to your
neighbors they know someone spirited in
your family one thing i love about my
mom is when she's cooking you know like
it's always delicious and she doesn't
take the compliment when you say oh it's
really delicious and she's always oh i
forgot to put something on it she never
take the compliment of the delicious
food that she made all the time i'm
always asking my mom to make me some
patches and uh she's always like oh yeah
i can do it for you but you guys need to
help me because there's a lot to do and
i'm always like oh of course mom i help
you and it's really funny when we
already like packing all the patches
because i don't have practice without
making the patches one it's too big and
the other one is too small and she's
always like do the right side do it the
right side and she's always mad at me
because of that when she's packing them
she's always like oh i forgot if i put
meat on that one i don't remember it so
she started all over again and it's
funny because it happens when you're
doing patches you're like oh i don't
know if i forget the meat which is
really important in the patches it was
really fun making all the tamales
together because you know like it was
always something for somebody to do the
way you can make the tamales faster that
way you can not get too tired doing by
yourself so because we were working uh
all together making the tamales that's
what uh it's a really special moment for
me to remember
hi i'm julisa and today i'm making
dominican pastelano
oh i feel like when i bite into a paste
and i get like that first bite it's like
a hint of savory but then you get that
little little sweetness in the back of
your palate dominican food is so
flavorful we don't like spicy contrary
to the belief of everyone thinking
latinos enjoy spicy food we don't our
spices come from just flavor you know
all around latino america everybody has
a lot of the same dishes but everyone
also puts their own twist on it and for
us we use platano which is like life in
dominican republic that's all we eat so
we just wrapped this plantain up in some
delicious ground beef and that's it it's
your snack it's your dinner it's your
side it's whatever you want to have
whenever it's made you know it's because
of the holidays and you know that it
just brings warmth and happiness to the
family and to me i that's usually what i
think of
you know i never get tired of saying why
i'm proud of being dominican as many
times as people ask me i love talking
about it just our culture of being such
happy and proud people and being proud
latinos and embracing every part of that
journey the laughter that we always
bring the humor
what's really interesting is i didn't
like pastelnojas when i was younger
i was like oh that's girls without
trying it and as i got older i remember
it was one christmas at my diapers house
and i loved it we put ketchup on it
after for me ketchup on it was like oh
the cherry on top now i can't go on
christmas without having it which is so
funny because i did a complete 360.
this
is good they just always remind me of my
mom they're delicious you really have to
try them it was the most delicious thing
i've ever had this is gonna make me
extremely happy oh yes
[Music]
you